ask not what your country can do for you
john f kennedy represented a breath of
fresh air as the nation entered the
decade of the sixties he was young
handsome and rich a war hero who just a
few years earlier
entered a storybook marriage with
jacqueline bouvier
as seen in this rare footage from the
wedding but for all his good qualities
jack kennedy had a wandering eye
and in las vegas he found a place that
could help satisfy his appetites
we are also the delighted to have in our
audience
senator john kennedy from the great
state of massachusetts
kennedy became friends with the infamous
rat pack in 1954
after charter member peter lawford
married into the kennedy clan
jfk partied with lawford frank sinatra
and other rat packers
both in hollywood and later in las vegas
while jackie stayed at home
newspaper records show kennedy's first
visit to las vegas was 1956.
he made a speech then met a string of
young women supplied by lawford and
sinatra
he was back again the following year for
another speech and more entertainment
according to lawford
along the way the senator became
acquainted with the men who ran las
vegas
including mob ambassador johnny roselli
family patriarch joe kennedy was already
well known to the mafia
including chicago kingpin sam giancana
the mob
overlord of las vegas the old man
kennedy was a very close friend of
giancanas they were in business together
in the old days in the bootlegging
business
kennedy made three trips to las vegas in
1960 and even won the endorsement of the
review
journal nevada and the nation voted
kennedy into office in november
frank sinatra accompanied jackie at the
inaugural ball
during the 1960 campaign while at the
sands hotel
jfk had been introduced by frank sinatra
to judith campbell
and they began a two-year affair that
later proved an embarrassment
campbell was simultaneously seeing sam
giancana and fbi boss j
edgar hoover found out about it 1962
saw another kennedy visit to las vegas
this time for a two hour inspection of
the test site
accompanied by nevada officials the
nevada public seemed to adore the
president but some las vegas residents
were upset
about a justice department crackdown on
the mafia mob leaders said they had
helped get kennedy elected and they
wanted the feds to back off
they were putting ungodly pressure on
sanji and khan as we all know
he was under surveillance 24 hours a day
in chicago
and finally got to him and he talked to
resulting said
tell us tell frank sinatra to talk to
the president after all we helped the
kennedys get elected
if sinatra did it didn't work fbi
wiretaps picked up giancana and other
mob leaders
plotting to kill kennedy roselli later
testified that the mafia had hired two
hit men to do the job
and a house subcommittee concluded it's
99 percent likely the mob killed jfk
becker among others believes the seeds
of that alleged conspiracy may have been
planted
here in las vegas i knew you know as we
all did here
the piccadillas of dear old president
john kennedy
when he was here but nevertheless
he was a human being